I've been trying to tell you for a long
time there's nobody that don't you would
you dad who off took the wrappers off
[__] whatever they should be that
[__] nuts to do something like that
me [__] that fool who put this
thing together me [__] oh you
miserable [__] Wednesday night
[Music]
did you talk to the dead I did
[__]
they said bet the [__] New England
next week beats Louis - [__] weasel
oh Jesus it smells like fungi tall
stinky [__] and I'm gorillas [__]
grows up in one of them greetings
[__] uncle Joey here you [__]
up
Motorhead do you can't cry over spilt
milk yet I'm saying I'm using her as a
[__] pipe cleaner now cuz that's all
she's ever [__] been you I'm almost
uncle Joey here hanging out happy to see
you
we had a great podcast tonight we'll get
[__] up as usual you know us we don't
[__] around here couple bong hits
just trying to cook this weed if you
live in the valley what do you wear
close to it the Skywalker that perennial
has right now will [__] you up again I
repeat if you're on the 18 hang up now
the Skywalker will [__] you up
no no this one this one is [__]
brutal brutal people walk out and
looking like Chris Weidman is [__] the
other one plan ahead what happened you
smoke the Skywalker [__]
that's like apartments now pipe [__] you
know saying and don't give up on us we
got the [__] everything look at this
we got individual boxes tonight you can
put them together open that [__]
I believe we're going deep into the
murky waters [__] whatever this [__]
this said dude was the other night I
went home and saw spirits I haven't seen
in years
we don't [__] around here
when something's good we double it
that's how we do it all denied open up
the door and get some fresh air this
[__]
was it polemically sand I want to know
what you met [__] get him Sam look
at this look at this it comes in little
[__] finest chocolate expresso
yummies crunch the boot yummy for your
[__] tumbler you understand me
Anna's got protein I'm looking
or we should we hear me right now the
taste is freezing y'all see what I do
four years of college again I'm loving
chocolate marijuana yeah mushroom we got
mushrooms the [__] you breathing for eat
that thing like a soldier you know you
don't like [__] chocolate
unbelievable it's [__] that you know
each other
you think he [__] eats it back you
don't like Chuck look the power of
Christ compels you did you know that we
[__] down a week and we're not
stopping now there you go he's
regurgitating pepper one get the water
let the chocolate hit your mouth a
little bell they're going to your
[__] name there you go hold on let me
get a mushroom you can mix it now will
mushroom cap in that tastes like the
[__] tastes like my toenail Sam
[Music]
hello
see how easy the system we don't [__]
around here we're just talking you like
that is we got our heads together
whether you're wringing it out you know
saying you don't want to read grandma's
medicine cabinet that's fine now you
ain't going nowhere
no Bond movies list yeah I'm not a
butter captain when we release real
quick I'll get you up the [__] second
keep that last piece of chocolate you
[__] Savage
you don't like to pieces hey what the
[__] have you been doing for the last 10
minutes oh look at this tonight it's
[__] movie a second
give it touch the eastern section that's
it that's it
you offended somebody will use
deflection that's [__] it it feels
like coconut milk is [__] we're gonna
talk about here it's [__] Wednesday
night your people are still home but
scared the Trump's are coming together
what the flop ain't nobody gonna get you
lisa has become the savages of savages
in the industry well here will quit you
understand me you got to do what you got
to do
beagle brother have a piece of this
questions what and they poison him say
it ain't [__] acid just let it out
okay you're gonna be fun I got little
ones for Vickie has a 50 milligram one
nobody gets a heart attack you say a
little something we dip it in Jersey
water to get your immune system up
that's right [__] did you say
Barnett I said Bob his father
no Bond movies this is it there's always
an eyewash you gonna do Dancing with the
[__] star CNN so they can put more
fear into it you're with Uncle Joe we
got it together we're gonna have a nice
podcast tonight Vicky press is here it's
all over husband's here Lee's here
that's all you [__] need to know
[__] now get that bottle ready
cuz we're going deep into the murky
waters gonna [__] underworld tonight
you know whether you want to do it in
that you're gonna sleep like a baby and
have dreams uncle Joey a house eating
Thanksgiving dinner as a matter of fact
will raffle that off right now we're
gonna [__] start the rap for tomorrow
if you win me and Lee Kum Kee house for
Thanksgiving we bring stars and we get
[__] up with your grandma you
understand me
if you don't have a grandma you can't
enter we don't want to deal with [__]
common folk we need grandparents will
dosed your grandparents [__] it we'll
pay for the hospital billions mother
please forgive them for they know not
what to do what's up a little Tarzan you
want smoke a little present my name is
Lenny if I ain't got it there ain't any
you don't play and if there's another he
must be my brother how's that one for
you when I was a kid too good times
had a thief on this show called wedding
and he was just bring [__] slow it and
he would say my name is money if I ain't
got it
there ain't any you got my brother
wedding I got like a half a flu so I
don't want to give you nothing
just in case Young Saeng let my mother
live it's all over she punched a ticket
38 years ago [__] you got a sing a
little song Osborn but see nothing
happened
you're still in one [__] piece will
listen to blizzard of aahhhs 1981 one of
the most importance of our [__] time
Ozzie left zappity had nowhere to go
he got Rudy Sarzo he got Randy Rhoads
and they put out a [__] tremendous
out that's how it works out
did I see them [__] yet at the Palladium
with Stephen Villa lubes and BT Quintero
vini got dry hump some guy tried to dry
hump him at the concert
he'd beat the [__] out and we had to
leave in a hurry but things happen at
the Palladium in the salmon that's why
you always got to bring a piece for a
toothpick or a lit cigarette you even
put a lit cigarette on somebody's back
and works at a concert they move
double-quick you're saying God will quit
[__]
[Music]
and that's it you don't even know what
to do with yourself you're like what
type of TV is this
this is [__] TV what entertainment
what plotlines it's just a fact what
with families smoking dope and talking
to you about carrier vets but guess what
I don't know nothing about carrot event
so I don't give a [__]
we're just here smoking and we'll make
it up as we go
[Laughter]
you're in training leaves and training
still he's going to be a Marine by the
end of the year you know our training
you know we train through we [__] die
understand
[Music]
nice and clear I got long boil is not a
bank
there's no THC juice to this thing that
most people have the dispensaries
[Music]
are you feeling all right
always a little magical mystery tour
when you team up with uncle Joey I think
that when we gotten them believe we got
we got hit water
we got pushy and we got [__] on it
tonight the seesaw in the house she said
saying don't forget Friday night I'm in
Houston have to come and take it
festival no [__] around dirty file day
pass you want to Todd Barry at 8:00
you watch me at 10:00 and that's it you
go home you [__] go to Chuy's and eat
that's it
and the next Wednesday we from tonight I
bet the Irvine improv the night before
Thanksgiving with Steve Simone and
you're also Lisa at I'm saying that's
our [__] put it together fear we're
gonna give you a real hot coming home
present at the Irvine improv tickets are
available don't knock yourself out let's
do another Polly's don't please don't be
so you want to smoke mama did they give
you a little bit there nobody don't jump
don't smoke out of that bomb cuz I'm
sick he's used to he calls I coffee
cause I call take it to the hoop Lee
show Vicki pezzi you ain't no punk [__]
so Vicki pester you ain't no punk [__]
take it to the hoop Lee there you go
ain't [__] around no more
oh [__] yet Skywalker
taking the places you've never been
before I'm sucking to my eyeballs look
at that resume [__] that that's
my [__] resume man [__] yourself how
the [__] do I know that's it dirty five
[__] years every duty look at that
there's blowing that eyeball everyone
look at that [__] resume you [__] i
times eight times just sniff my nutsack
I'm saying they sniffing yeah yeah
you're gonna write about we with you
what are you gonna write about you just
graduated car you but smoking dope for
three [__] years
your mom is a half a hippy they called
you sunshine and you look more and you
live off your dad's credit card you got
a shop and my [__] place of business
what are you [__] not so what
I got emotional about [__] sunshine
[Music]
don't get no better than that I don't
know we hanging out with it we ain't
hanging out with well Uncle Joe is here
[__] Vicky PES is here
[Music]
like wine tonight give you a love and it
will come to shoot yeah are you [__]
nuts or what
[Music]
got a week's up thanksgiving get it
together
[Music]
I'm feeling good you're feeling good
what else you offering me what else you
want a bedtime [__] story
I got no bedtime stories my pain is
going to go to sleep well your pajamas
are I'll pay the [__] slow give me
two minutes I'll flip the ow
sure
yeah but your pajamas not brush your
teeth no [__] it and I get a glass of
warm milk
this is uncle Joey's bed time stories
[__] here we go
[Music]
are you [__] kidding me or what can
you sit there listen to [__] the [__]
you listen
Chuchu what
[Applause]
[Music]
it's bedtime did you do a bond it you
have to a bomb it before you ready
farmville Joey's bedtime stories
[Applause]
anyway let's have a bedtime story you
want I can't tell you a sexy woman
please you'll [__] pre-cum and you'll
ruin the [__] bed sheet so I have to
tell you something like the avatar type
of situation
you know what I got no [__] stories
there I'm all [__] out of [__]
stories
you guys gave me this weed you make me
smoke edibles you know what the [__] is
wrong with you what the [__] is wrong
with you you people know I'm not on
medication the woman I'm putting the
pieces together yet the snapping
[Music]
look you're picking passes new hairdo oh
[__] yeah it looks great
take nothing up and coming up another
what are you gonna do what your life you
looking at me France I got no answers
I handle appear 53 in a [__] room
with fake bricks I'm sad
what the [__] you think I'm done I'm
going straight to hell with I am basket
but at least I know that going in and I
got no moral sense cuz I've never
murdered nobody if you don't go to
church it's a mortal sin but [__] you I
go in my head I go the [__] Church
dude said you have to come to church
home on Sundays so I got no moral sense
I went up a purgatory couple thousand
years I bump into some [__] weird
people and that's it
so beautiful evening enjoy [__]
nobody ever told me I found out for
myself
you gotta believe in foolish miracles
you do at night that's how you play the
game it's if you win or lose you can
choose you can't choose both you ain't
losin it's that type of party it's 2016
Trump is slinging dick and giving our
bubble gum Hillary's taking it to the
presses
that's it it's tides up to you alright I
got no answers you know who you want
answers go to youtube.com slash c / Joey
Diaz one more time if you're deaf hit
that [__] day maybe youtube.com nice
to hobb /c / Joey Diaz give me 10
minutes really get pulled up in I got
some right way I got some white heroin
that just got in and it's over we'll be
with you in 10 minutes stay black you
know we love
[Music]